[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
wazir avec vous retrouver pour 13
minutes d'idées sorties tout de suite le
sommaire de ce jeudi 15 novembre le club
d'elancourt maurepas accueille ce
week-end les compétitions inter
départemental de gymnastique rythmique
nous avons suivi un cours des jeunes
filles du chlore en compétition les
filles 2 0 jeunes 0 gêne le club
d'ultimate frisbee de plaisir remettre
ça après le succès de la première
édition de leur tournoi féminin
il était indispensable de le continuer
sandra martineau sera avec nous pour en
parler et pour sa 4ème édition du trap
impro family déclic théâtre mise sur ses
anciens juniors les matchs
d'improvisation s'ouvre vendredi 16
novembre à la merise et la fédération
française de gymnastique et le club de
gymnastique rythmique d'elancourt
maurepas organise une compétition
régionale samedi 17 et dimanche 18
novembre au palais des sports de pau
palais des sports 700 gymnastes
viendront s'affronter et tenter de se
qualifier pour l'étape suivante pouvoir
mener au championnat de france
nous avons justement suivi un
entraînement de compétition au club un
des trois quarts l'entraînement est
intensif pour les jeunes gymnastes ont
compétition du club de gymnastique
rythmique d'elancourt maurepas 19 heures
d'entraînement par semaine auxquels
s'ajoutent des stages pendant les
vacances scolaires
chaque séance commence par une bonne
heure d'échauffement des 3 4 les filles
passent ensuite aux engins pour les
compétitions chaque gymnaste prépare un
enchaînement 2 minutes 30 avec un engin
imposé par la fédération c'est un
enchaînement qui entraîneurs préparent
que recherchent les musiques laethem en
lointaine chinois on coupe la musique
c'est énorme travail et après on
travaille ça pour préparer pour
compétition les filles se donnent à fond
pour ce sport mêlant la technique la
souplesse et l'artistique bananarama v1
et voir un gala de gym ici et puis j'ai
adoré du coup bas
en effet bas c'était le fait de pouvoir
essayer de me dépasser et faire mon
possible le plus pour évoluer c'est des
êtres ban d'être mieux placé
c'est d'aimer pointe et direct tony
claude auxerre et un cerf la professeur
russe fait du repérage dès le plus jeune
âge les petites semaines aux
entraînements des plus grandes qui leur
montre la voie plus on commence tôt et
plus on se plie aux règles et plus c'est
facile
en fait pour travailler la souplesse
pour travailler la technique c'est des
bases qu'il faut acquérir très vite
parce que la gérer c'est une carrière à
une carrière qui s'arrêtent très tôt une
méthode qui porte ses fruits morgan a
fait partie de l'équipe de france sa
carrière de gymnaste de haut niveau
terminé elle aime revenir dans son club
de coeur
donner un coup de main à son ancien
coach et pour les encourager et assister
au spectacle de leur performance rendez
vous samedi et dimanche au palais des
sports à elancourt elles étaient une
cinquantaine l'année dernière à
s'affronter pour la seule compétition
féminine d'ultimate frisbee
d'ile-de-france 0 gêne le club du petit
mètre de plaisir renouvelle smooth
érotique
le tournoi amical aura lieu ce samedi et
dimanche au palais des sports à plaisir
avec nous en plateau sandra martin au
bon jour bonjour alors vous êtes co
organisatrice de l'événement tout
d'abord qu'est-ce que l'ultimate frisbee
et comment en pratique
l'ultimate frisbee c'est donc un sport
d'équipé ou deux équipes s'affrontent
le principe de jeu s'est basé sur le gan
terrain donc chaque équipe doit a pour
objectif de marquer un point en gagnant
la zone d'en but en soi en se faisant
des passes avec le frisbee comme au
rugby il est impossible de marcher avec
le frisbee donc on
obligé de faire des passes et on a un
laps de temps pour le faire
voilà donc là ce week-end c'est un fort
du tournoi c'est quoi comment ça se
passe notre canton masse et des équipes
qui s'affrontent alors ça reste des
équipes qui s'affrontent effectivement
tournoi ça veut dire que ça ne fait pas
partie du championnat fédéral de frisbee
d'ultimate donc en fait le principe est
exactement le même le but pour chacune
des équipes c'est de s'affronter en
faisant des matches et marqué le plus de
points
il y aura également une fin une gagnante
qui sera demain qui sera effectivement
avec vous pour deux récompensés à la fin
du tournoi et donc ce tournoi il est
100% féminin c'est une formule qui avait
disparu en ile-de-france tout à fait
donc le club de plaisir voulait remettre
ça en place puisque il n'y avait plus de
tournois féminins actuellement parce que
généralement c'est mixte
c'est un sport mixte tout à fait donc
là c'est la spécificité de ce tournoi
c'est la féminité donc l'année dernière
il y avait cinq équipes inscrites cette
année vous mais dès qu'il en avait six
équipes à dire que ça prend petit mais
ça prend bien ça prend un petit peu
exactement chaque année on si on arrive
à obtenir une équipe de plus ce serait
déjà une grande victoire
alors la petite petite particularité de
ce sport c'est que ce sont les joueurs
eux mêmes
même les joueurs qui s'inviteront tout à
fait c'est basé sur l'auto arbitrage
il n'ya pas d'arbitré chaque joueur doit
éviter tout contact avec avec l'autre et
prévenir s'il y a un contact annoncé que
l'on a fait une faute sur l'autre choix
parce que le fair-play c'est important
de dire que même ça c'est récompenser
tout à fait à chaque tournoi et
championnat d'ailleurs il y a toujours
un gagnant de fair play
chaque équipe mais des notes aux équipes
qu'elles affrontent et à la fin du
tournoi il n'ya le vainqueur du tournoi
est également le vainqueur du fair play
celui qui a eu le meilleur état d'esprit
tout au long du championnat ou du
tournoi donc il y aura deux types de
mach les matchs classiques et des rates
ses collègues différend à la différence
des par rapport au match classique c'est
que dans l'est at on a mélangé chacune
des joueuses des équipes pour refaire de
nouvelles équipes qu'on appelle un petit
peu plus fun et l'âme le coup ça permet
vraiment de jouer avec toutes les
joueuses des autres clubs
vous savez république on peut venir vous
encourager tout à fait tous le samedi et
le dimanche
très bien merci sont d'un martineau
d'être vigilant au plateau le tournoi 0
tic deuxième édition c'est samedi et
dimanche 18 novembre au palais des
sports à plaisir et d'autres rendez vous
sportif ce week-end le badminton club de
montigny le bretonneux organise son 10e
sky bad un tournoi de badminton par
équipes quatre séries sont proposés les
doubles dames et doubles hommes auront
lieu le samedi et les doubles mixtes le
dimanche vous pourrez venir et assister
aux jeunes au gymnase pierre de
coubertin du handball en nationale 3
plaisir reçoit bois-colombes sport pour
cette septième journée de championnat un
match important pour les plaisirs wa ils
doivent l'emporter pour remonter au
classement ils sont actuellement 10e sur
12 équipes
vous pouvez les soutenir et gymnase
nicolas hasler à plaisir ce dimanche 18
novembre à 16 heures et pour notre petit
tour dans les selles saint-quentinoise
pâtre jacques de dixmude s'est rendu à
tra
le cinéma le grenier à sel offre une
programmation spéciale pour la semaine
de l'éducation à trappes du 19 au 24
novembre l'éducation est mise en avant
c'est à l'occasion de la signature du
projet éducatif de territoire que la
ville
promeut tout ce qui est fait en termes
d'éducation donc il ya des ateliers des
projections des rencontres et au cinéma
le grenier à sel
il y aura le vendredi 23 novembre à
20h45 la projection d'un documentaire
qui s'appelle une idée folle qui pose la
question du rôle de l'école 21e siècle à
travers le témoignage d'enseignants
d'enfants de parents ainsi que d'experts
de l'éducation
la réalisatrice viendra donc vendredi 23
novembre à 20h45 au cinéma le grenier à
sel
tous nos déchets base va la cantine
weeds et plus j'y reste vanhée mais là
dedans il a déjà demandé des melons des
fruits on leur apprend à être pour être
dans notre construction pas être content
à toujours se plaindre toute leur vie
que mon dieu c'est horrible tout ce qui
m'arrive et ça va pas non mais qu'est-ce
que je peux faire pour que ça bouge
tienne citoyenneté en action
et puis quand on sera plus grands on
fera plus des petites choses mais on
fera des grandes choses une plus grande
pour essayer de plus changer du cinéma
au théâtre depuis quatre ans la grande
famille de déclic théâtre se réunit pour
le trap impro family l'édition 2018
c'est ce vendredi 16 novembre à la
merise les équipes s'affronteront lors
de matchs d'improvisation dans les
règles de l'art cette année pour fêter
les 25 ans sont les anciens juniors qui
reviennent pour cette spéciale juniors
all stars n'ouvrez iachini louise
arbitrerait les rencontres une rôle
phare ça veut dire que l'on va
accueillir en très très grande partie
des personnes qui ont participé à
l'équipe des juniors qui est un petit
peu l'équipe phare de transmettre en
avant ici à déclic c'est les 15-18
et voilà on fait appel au haut à ceux
qui ont une aventure de comédiens
aujourd'hui et qui sont passés par
parler par l'école entre guillemets des
démineurs de tram trappe un prophète
milly commence à 20h30 ce vendredi 16
novembre à l'amour is une quatrième
édition également pour le festival de
bandes annonces de bois d'arcy ce week
end
un rendez vous devenu incontournable
pour la commune qui met en valeur le
travail réalisé sur une bande annonce
la soirée aura lieu le samedi 7 novembre
au cinéma de la grange cette année le
béaba année à l'honneur lino ventura
j'en fais n'est plus adjoint au maire en
charge de la culture de bois d'arcy
était sur le plateau de cette ville
culture pour nous expliquer ce choix on
est pile entre le centenaire de sa
naissance et le trentenaire de sa de son
décès de sa disparition c'est la neige
un peu charnière on il est à l'honneur à
bonnart 6 depuis le début de l'année on
a mis son nom sur sur une maison des
associations dans le fameux quartier de
la croix bonnet et son fils laurent sera
présent et on aura des échanges avec lui
et pour décrypter les bandes-annonces de
ses principaux films et pas que les plus
connus au long de la
la version junior est proposée le
lendemain pour découvrir toutes les
bandes annonces des films d'animation
pour enfants programmé dans les mois à
venir
du 17 au 25 novembre c'est la semaine du
jeu à saint quentin en yvelines
cela commence dès samedi au complexe
sportif alain mimoun avis
re pour les festives eu plusieurs
espaces du jeu de rôle aux jeux vidéo et
même un tournoi d'escrimé de troll bol
dans l'univers de l'héroïque fantaisie
n'hésitez pas à venir déguisés laisse
parler son coeur c'est l'opération
solidaire des malus les écosystèmes à
laquelle participent versailles grand
parc durant la semaine européenne de
réduction des déchets du 17 au 25
novembre
vous pouvez apporter les jouets que vos
enfants n'utilisent plus ils seront
nettoyés remis en état pour faire le
bonheur d'enfants dans le besoin une
note pour la collecte est disponible au
siège de la communauté d'agglomération
[Musique]
et pour notre briques sortie en
ile-de-france direction le grand palais
de paris
le monument bordure des champs elysées
vous promenez vous propose une plongée
dans la venise du xviiie siècle
nicolas léoz le hérissé de nos confrères
via comparer a pris place à bord d'une
gondole
que diriez-vous d'une promenade en
gondole dans la venise du xviiie siècle
à cette époque la ville est alors au
sommet de sa gloire et de son faste et
tous les plaisirs y sont permis la
sérénissime brille dans tous les
domaines artistiques peinture sculpture
théâtre musique
l'exposition du grand palais retrace
cette période de fêtes et de créativité
intense où la cité des doges attiré tous
les regards
au xviiie siècle venise était un lieu de
divertissement pour toute l'europe
on venait pour le carnaval qui duré
presque six mois d'octobre à l'ascension
on venait aussi pour l'opéra on venait
pour écouter la musique dans les aspects
d'alice et institutions pieuse l'an les
jeunes filles apprenait la musique quand
on pense à venise on n'imagine pas
l'importance de la sculpture mais on
trouve des sculptures sur les façades
des églises il y a des sculpteurs comme
corradini qui réussit à faire deviner le
visage d'une femme à travers un voile de
marbre et puis on venait aussi pour la
ville la ville extraordinaire cette
ville construite sur l'eau avec ses
palais de marbre qui se reflète sur le
grand canal le luxe de ses palais ses
traditions artistiques son régime
politique originale rendent venise
attractive et singulière des grands
peintres comme tiepolo au canaletto
raconte la beauté et la puissance de la
cité opéra théâtre de marionnettes la
musique était aussi omniprésente dans
les rues
admirer à travers toute l'europe l'art
vénitien s'exporte partout en angleterre
en espagne et jusqu'en france
on a beaucoup d'informations sur la vie
à venise par les correspondances des
visiteurs étrangers comme le président
de broches jean jacques rousseau qui est
venu à venise aussi la vie musicale
n'était pas réservé à l'opéra au théâtre
et aux aspects dali il y avait des
concerts un peu partout sur les camps
pieri on dit que les gondoliers chante
merveilleusement et donc ont trouvé la
musique à chaque pas dans vénus une cité
éblouissante qui derrière le fasse un
parent déclinera jusqu'à l'arrivée de
napoléon et la chute de la république en
1797 et c'est la fin de ce neuvième
numéro de votre set it was here merci de
nous avoir suivis je vous donne rendez
vous la semaine prochaine et vous
souhaite une bonne soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
où